I remember when I was six and I begged
mom and dad to let me go to the science
Expo in Midway and we got a flat tire on
that dirt road no spare so we were toned
to that garage in a tiny little one
street town of course we were stuck
there all day and we got ice cream and
french fries with gravy at that little
diner and then that night we watched the
local fireworks show actually turned out
to be a great day and it's my favorite
memory it's mom and dad what was the
name of that town he said Bill
I'm still in there
piece of advice stop trying to beat
savat are at his own game their goodness
is your strength call me sentimental
slash should have been a hero
the flash season finale Tuesday at 8/7
central on the CW happy flash day as
expected they drop some new footage and
we get a deep dive with savitur and
Barry in how he might be solving the
problem with some advice from Captain
Cold
so there's a new render the flash ring
giveaway but they drop a couple of these
drags they talk about Midway city in
Masonville those are two big cities from
DC Comics history but I think you know
in the larger context to talk about that
first is its avatars greatest weapon
against Barry isn't his speed but that's
pretty badass he's the fastest version
of the flash that we've ever seen but
his true power is having all of Barry's
memories as he learned them in real time
so everything that Barry remembers sabot
are instantly remembers so he's telling
him this story here about how he and his
parents were going to go to this big
science fair in Masonville but they got
stuck in the little town and it turns
into this really touching story about
them spending time together as a family
that's my favorite memory of mom and dad
what was the name of that town so in his
mind like Barry is remembering this is
he's talking to sabotage so you see like
the couple second delay as it sort of
clicks and sabotage head and he
remembers to Masonville Midway's the
city where Hawkman and Hawkgirl are from
I know we haven't seen them in a while
they'll probably pop back up in the
future season but Masonville actually
showed up in a Superman comic where like
this little kid writes to the Daily
Planet this fantastic story like he's
dressed up here like Superman they get
caught in this big adventure Superman
saves him so he's talking to him here's
Clark Kent you know thank you for the
really awesome letter that you wrote
into The Daily Planet
so it was just this funny side adventure
it wasn't like a particularly huge or
earth-shattering story but that kind of
ties in with Barry's story it's not this
big
earth-shattering thing it's just this
really nice story about his family being
together so the key thing here is this
reminds you of this scene of iris
touching his face and he doesn't look
like he has any hate left in him like
he's remembering and he's really sad so
that might be a scene from the fan
it might be a deleted scene but it just
all goes back to the idea that Savitt r
is also going to help solve this big
problem that he himself has created
although technically Barrie created it
because he's a version of Barry so it's
been this crazy domino effect we can
talk after the season is over about how
it all worked out because there were
some really cool ideas like I felt that
they had and some of them just didn't
pan out quite as well as they'd hope but
a lot of this just due to the problems
of trying to plot out a 23 episode
season and they usually don't know the
entire plot when they start they knew
about the Sava tarde twist when they
started that's the big consequence of
flashpoint Barry saves his mother and it
leads to a really awful version of
himself rising in the future changing
things as he will just as soon as own
wins it's kind of a version of what the
reverse-flash does the reverse-flash is
very open very careful about surgically
altering his own timeline there's a
really cool Geoff Johns flashpoint story
that sort of retells his origin story
it's not relevant to this so we can talk
about it when we get to season 4 stuff
but wouldn't it be crazy if saboteur is
the one to save iris and he gets to be
the hero of the day it's not so much
Barry because this is all about Barry's
failure it sounds like kind of a bummer
when we talk about it that way but if
you think about it Barry got that lesson
in episode 16 in the speedforce this is
really the comeuppance the ultimate
realization of his failure in that
leading to sabotage so it sounds like
he's trying to inspire him to be good
again remind him of who he is the Barry
that's inside of him and not thus avatar
that he's become just like he tried to
reignite hope inside the Future team
flash but I just keep going back to why
that version of Barry didn't say
anything about Savitt are being a
version of him maybe he never took the
costume off maybe he never figured it
out there's a couple ways to explain how
future Barry from 2024 could traps
avatar in the speedforce
without getting the mask off I know that
was one of the biggest questions because
it's like hey wait a minute missing
information you forgot to tell us
thats avatar is a version of me with a
waffle face like he got it burned in a
big buyer or something when I see little
problems like that that don't quite make
sense I usually try to think about what
the writers intended so and I think in
this moment they intended for the future
version of Barry to not know who
avatar was that he was one of the time
remnants he created two stops avatar
previously that didn't work out when it
comes to really big problems like the
cliffhanger that they're teasing in the
finale here berry you know maybe going
into the Speed Force and not being
around that's different they intend that
to be incredibly opaque like they want
you to wonder oh my god is he ever
coming back wish you know spoiler alert
yeah of course Berry is always going to
come back because Grant Gustin is the
main actor on the show they tried to do
the same thing on arrow during season 3
where they made it seem like they killed
Stephen Amell like Raja Ghul stabbed him
and kicked him off a mountaintop so he
was on the edge of death but that was
episode 9 so it was like a midseason
cliffhanger they brought him right back
to life in episode 10 when they came
back so I try not to hold stuff against
them like that because I really like the
characters if the show was like really
really bad I would probably still watch
it I watched all 10 seasons of
Smallville not all of those 10 seasons
were very good but you loved the
Superman character so much that you just
stick it out you're like okay what's
superman doing this week was the crazy
adventure okay the tan is here and
that's also you know people pretending
to be killed off the show the show
making you feel like they're getting rid
of characters the iris West character is
such a fundamental part of the Barry
Allen character that I feel like they
can make you wonder what's going to
happen to her they can take her away for
a little while but you can't ever
completely get rid of her so there were
a lot of funny theories on the last
video that I posted people were like hey
why don't they get an alternate universe
version of iris that they kill in this
moment like I said I think this is all
Barry post iris trying to appeal to
Savitt are in sabotage going to be the
ones that leads the plan to bring her
back because he'll remember how he cared
for her it's probably the biggest leap
in logic of the show that he would kill
the person that this version of Barry
our version is so in love with after
everything they've been through this
season that's where I've seen most of
the people in my social feeds
complaining just because Barry proposed
to her after that musical episode so
it's like wait a minute right after that
you're telling me that Savitt r wants to
kill her that just sounds ridiculous so
I feel like the twist was a little too
big a little too fast it probably would
have worked better if Barry and iris had
already been married in a future season
so I think it'll all be better in season
4 they can focus on more
or rogue characters they'll still be a
lot of multiverse stuff but I will do a
season 4 predictions video after I do my
finale video and big news there's a
spider-man homecoming trailer there's
probably a game of Thrones trailer
dropping in the next day and I'm going
to be posting my non-spoilery Wonder
Woman review in addition to the arrow
Deathstroke finale there's so much stuff
happening this week it is going to be
awesome I'll remind everyone about the
flash ring giveaway when I post my
episode video tonight and for those of
you that are wondering the flash ring
giveaway will still continue through the
off season week to week so I'll still be
doing all that kind of stuff it'll be
great
but while you wait for that you can
click here for more new flash and you
can click here for brand-new Game of
Thrones thank you so much for watching
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you